Barack Obama is back with his take on
2018 Hillary Clinton learns to love
federalism and the anti-science left
take center stage I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
you thought he was gone you thought he
wouldn't be back what wrong you are he's
back and we'll talk about him in just a
second but first let's talk about all of
the events surrounding election 2018 if
you look at the rhetoric from the
leftist news outlets on the heels of
Brett Cavanaugh's confirmation they're
trying to solidify the left for the
midterms it is going to be a battle to
hold the house here's what's at stake if
the Democrats take it all the positive
policies Republicans have enacted over
the past couple of years all the things
to help the economy the tax cuts the
judicial appointments the cutting of the
regulations all of it could be stymied
if the Democrats take control of either
the house or the Senate and when they
start to obstruct what effect could that
have on the economy on stocks and other
unknowns that might impact your savings
what is your plan for uncertainty can
you afford another hit to your
retirement like the last downturn when
the S&P dropped 50% well you should
hedge against inflation and hedge
against uncertainty and instability with
some precious metals gold is a safe
haven against uncertainty my savings
plan is diversified yours should be too
doesn't mean take all your money and
stick it in gold I mean think some of
your money and put it in precious metals
the company I trust with precious metal
purchases is Birch gold group and right
now thanks to a little-known IRS tax law
you can even move that IRA or eligible
401k into an IRA backed by physical gold
and silver perfect for folks who want to
protect their hard-earned retirement
savings from future geopolitical
uncertainty Birch gold group has
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau contact
Birch gold group now request a free
information kit on physical precious
metals it's a comprehensive 16 page kit
and it shows again how you can move gold
can move your IRA or 401k out of stocks
into a precious metals IRA to get that
kit
go to birchgold.com slash pen again it's
no cost into obligation birchgold.com
slash ben burtt scold the folks I trust
with precious metals investing well we
are watching in the news as the country
seems to be on the verge of something
really really terrible it seems like
something that's that's building up
frankly on both sides a couple of
parallel stories that are really ugly
over the last 24 hours Story number one
George Soros who is not a person I
admire in any way George Soros of course
a leftist funder of a bunch of radical
causes but he is not a person who ought
to be murdered and yet an explosive
device was found in the mailbox at his
home
Monday afternoon according to senior law
enforcement is occurring in the New York
Times
the device was proactively D notated by
bomb squad technicians from the
Westchester County Police Department the
Bombers motive remains unclear Soros is
a favorite target of right-wing groups
he was not at home at the time the
investigation has been taken over by the
FBI all of this is ugly stuff now again
I am no George Soros fan I think that
George Soros does terrible terrible
things for world politics and I think he
backs awful causes that doesn't mean
that folks who go out bombing him this
is insanity and it's not just George
Soros according to the Daily Caller
House Majority Leader Kevin McCarthy's
office in California was vandalized on
Monday according to an Instagram post by
the congressman McCarthy who could be
the future Speaker of the House his
local offices in Bakersfield California
he posted photos of the suspects in some
of the damage two young men were caught
on surveillance camera outside the
office it had its windows smashed in by
a large boulder and he doesn't know
exactly who these folks are he put out
the notice McCarthy's office of course
is not the first GOP office to be
vandalized in recent weeks a Republican
Party office in Wyoming was
intentionally set on fire two days after
it opened in September vandals later hit
the Metropolitan Republican Club on
Manhattan's Upper East Side in October
smashing windows and spray-painting
anarchist signs on the doors so all just
wonderful stuff and yesterday there is a
dangerous situation in Washington DC a
suspected intruder was shot after
kicking down the glass doors at WTTG Fox
5 on Monday he was previously known to
both Fox executives and police had
leveled threats against both previously
DC police responded to the building on
Wisconsin Avenue in the Friendship
Heights neighborhood as officials say
that the man had been shot in the
station's Lobby by an armed security
guard after forcing his way through the
glass doors his name was George
Odom's and he apparently started walking
directly toward the decks desk station
in the direction of the main part of the
building at that point the security
guard shot the guy he is in critical but
stable condition it's apparently this
guy has mental health issues but the
problem is that we now live in a society
in which we don't know who has mental
health issues and who is being
politically motivated and who has mental
health issues and is being politically
motivated we are living in an incredibly
volatile time and that's unusual because
the economy of the United States is
thrumming along mail order
really well economically speaking we're
not in the middle of any major foreign
crisis and yet we're at each other's
throats politically and the bleeding
edge of that fight is actually bleeding
I mean the bleeding edge actually
carries the possibility of serious
violence heating up with the rhetoric on
both sides is obviously not a worthwhile
causing yet that seems to be happening
Barack Obama who was one of the
contributing factors to the breakdown in
social fabric in the United States
during his presidency he continued that
crusade yesterday he was campaigning in
Nevada against Dean Heller who's the
sitting senator and he just made clear
that the sort of political polarization
that he supposedly preaches against he's
actually very much for here's President
Obama back on the stump for the
Democrats and he is saying that
President Trump is a tin-pot dictator
it is not a democratic or republican
idea that we are not supposed to
pressure the Attorney General or the FBI
to use the criminal justice system to
try to punish political opponents that's
not how America works that's how some
tin-pot dictatorship works that's not
supposed to be America okay well here's
the problem and this is really the
problem with with President Obama you're
gonna see this repeated throughout his
little speech that he gave yesterday
Nevada everything he accuses the right
of doing he actually did while he was in
office he says things like you're not
supposed to influence the FBI you're not
supposed to influence your Attorney
General his own attorney General Eric
Holder called himself Barack Obama's
wingman that was Eric Holder his own DOJ
head calling himself the president's
wingman the president is asserted
executive privilege to protect Eric
Holder from a Republican Congress over
the Fast and Furious scandal so this is
just nonsense and when the president
says that you're not supposed to
activate executive agencies to target
political opponents that's exactly what
his I arrested his IRS targeted
conservative 501 C 3 s pro-israel 501 C
3 s the evidence was extraordinarily
solid in that case the DOJ didn't do a
serious investigation nor did they
prosecute anybody so when the president
says that President Trump is doing all
the stuff when Obama says that Trump is
doing all of this stuff just remember
president Trump is a reaction to
President Obama and the more you look at
American history and history in general
what you really do see is that
the the the nature of the human being is
to swing from side to side that we react
to things that happen in our life and we
usually overreact to things that happen
in our life so we are react to President
Bush by putting in President Obama then
react but to President Obama by putting
in President Trump that the pendulum in
order for it to to start swinging less
wildly it takes a force of collective
will it takes all of us saying to each
other we are not going to allow this
pendulum to swing quite as wildly as it
has been in the past if you look at the
vacillations between the presidencies
right now I would say that if you looked
back in the 1960s like the difference
between say LBJ and Richard Nixon on
policy what you were looking at was a
vet was a vacillation that was semi
major but not enormous right the the the
swing of the pendulum was not quite as
far the same thing is true with
Eisenhower and JFK the swing of the
pendulum was not quite that far if you
look at how far the pendulum is swinging
now it's almost at 180 degrees I mean
the pendulum is swinging wildly
side-to-side and that's dangerous for
the country because eventually the
pendulum is going to swing over the bar
and things are gonna get really insane
President Obama did not help that this
this revisionist history where President
Obama was a great peace Springer this is
this this revisionist history where
President Obama did not create conflict
inside the United States where he was a
unifying figure as opposed to a
polarizing figure that is just a lie
when he was elected maybe he was a
unifying figure for five minutes and
then he proceeded to govern as an
extraordinarily far left guy and then he
also proceeded to polarize the country
along ethnic racial and sexual lines
it's a real it's just it's obvious that
he's doing this he trolled the right
into insanity and now President Trump is
trolling the left into insanity this is
all reactionary stuff here's President
Obama again he's such a troll he's such
a troll when people accuse President
Trump of being a troll I'd like to
remind folks the first presidential
troll was Barack Obama here's President
Obama trolling people in Nevada
yesterday saying that he was very
committed to the truth as presidents of
the United States
just one simple fact this is a fact this
is not I'm just unlike some I actually
try to state facts I believe in facts
I I believe in a fact-based reality and
a fact-based politics okay that is just
a lie he did not believe in a fact-based
reality of fact-based politics it's just
not true and he says that he didn't lie
hidden liked to fib like some people
really how about if you like your doctor
you can keep your doctor how about if
the president the president doesn't have
authority to grants executive amnesty
how about those men died in Benghazi
because of a YouTube video how about the
Iran deal is being pursued because of a
new moderate policy pushed by the new
Iranian moderate administration the
president lied every five seconds Barack
Obama was a congenital liar while he was
in office and he was replaced by a guy
who doesn't have tremendous regard for
the truth either
again reaction and American politics is
is almost completely proportionate
Barack Obama was very far to the left
and Donald Trump is his funhouse mirror
image and when and when Barack Obama
says things like he tries to state facts
and Donald Trump just goes out there and
he lies all the time it's just not true
I like when he says that he's based on
that he's based in fact there's a
President of the United States who took
title mine of the Civil Rights Act which
said you're not allowed to discriminate
against women and tried to apply that to
men who believe they are women saying
that this was somehow
fact-based almost nothing the Barack
Obama did was fact-based almost nothing
he did was fact-based and this is why so
many people reacted to Barack Obama they
said listen if facts don't matter the
left well maybe they don't matter to us
either all that matters now is victory
because that was the mentality of the
left the mentality of the left was that
slandering george w bush as a war
criminal was fully justified in order to
get Barack Obama elected that slandering
John McCain as george w bush part 3 was
totally fine so long as it got barack
obama elected that slandering mitt
romney as a dog killing evil genius who
gave women cancer specifically so that
he could fire their husbands right that
that was totally fine so long as he won
that harry reid was fine and saying that
mit romney didn't pay his taxes because
after all they won this stuff does not
spring from nowhere in american politics
hey evil and american politics the the
nastiness of american politics did not
spring out of the ground full-blown like
thena out of Zeus's head that's not the
way this works Barack Obama was the
progenitor of Donald Trump Barack Obama
was the was the predictable forbear of
Donald Trump in retrospect a second
we're gonna give you some more of Barack
Obama's propaganda and the fact that the
left doesn't even acknowledge any of
this is one of the reasons why the right
continues to act the way the right is
acting we'll get to more of that in just
a second first I want to talk about what
you are doing for the sheets in your bed
okay the fact is that when you think
about your sleep quality you rarely
think about your sheets you think okay
well I can just go down to the local Bed
Bath and Beyond I can pick up the
cheapest set of sheets they've got and
it will be perfectly adequate wrong that
you are that is not the way this works
you need supremely comfortable sheets
and the best sheets you can buy the best
sheets on the market our bull and branch
everything bull and branch makes from
bedding to blankets is made from pure
100% organic cotton it means it starts
out super soft they get even softer over
time you can buy directly from them so
you're essentially paying wholesale
prices luxury sheets can cost up to a
thousand dollars in the store but when
branch sheets are only a couple of
hundred bucks everyone who tries Boleyn
branch sheets loves them that's why they
have thousands of five-star reviews even
three u.s. presidents sleep on bull and
branch sheets shipping is free you can
try them for 30 nights if you don't love
them send them back for a refund you're
not gonna want to send them back they
are that comfortable to get you started
right now my listeners get 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets at bull and
branch calm promo code Ben bull and
branch calm promo code Ben for 50 bucks
off your first set of sheets these
sheets are so comfortable actually
tossed out all of our other sheets we
only own Boland branch now that's how
good they are Bo LLM branch calm promo
code Ben used that promo code bed to get
fifty bucks off so Barack Obama is a
great reminder as to why Donald Trump is
president and then he tried to take
credit in Nevada last night for the way
the economy is growing now let's be
clear the stock market did climb under
Barack Obama because it fell to all-time
lows under Barack Obama also right
you'll recall that the economy collapsed
in late 2008 right before the election
that wasn't on Obama and then it
continued to collapse until early 2009
and then it started to recover and then
we had the slowest peacetime recovery in
American history
yeah I'm old enough to remember when
folks were saying things like a 4% GDP
growth rate is no longer possible for
the United States and now we have had
that for a couple of quarters in a row
I'm old enough to remember when people
said that the manufacturing sector in
the United States was doomed to failure
that obviously is not true when folks
were say
the stock market was gonna top out where
Obama left it that obviously was not
true that job creation was going to top
out that obviously was not true there's
no question the economy is growing
faster under Donald Trump than it was
under Barack Obama it is superheated
under Donald Trump in a way that it was
not under Barack Obama again very very
slow recovery under Obama and whatever
recovery is due to Obama you really can
only attribute for the first couple of
years because after that it was the
Republicans stymieing every budget that
Obama tried to propose Obama passed one
budget in eight years Republicans
rejected every budget proposal Barack
Obama ever made and yet here is Barack
Obama saying that if anybody gets credit
for the economy it's him now listen I'm
never a fan of crediting the president
with the economy I just don't I think
the economy is too complicated for that
I usually think that it has more to do
with a predictable policy emanating from
the halls of Congress the fact is that
since Republicans were elected in 2010
we've had a consistent rate of growth in
the United States economy accelerating
when they didn't have to battle it out
with Barack Obama over regulatory policy
if you actually want to attribute
economic growth to any one body give the
credit to Paul Ryan Mitch McConnell and
all the other Republicans who have been
instrumental in the formation of policy
under Obama and under Trump but here's
Barack Obama trying to take credit for
himself
we got the economy growing again we
started the longest streak of job
creation on record we covered another
twenty million people on health
insurance
we brought housing back here in Nevada
we cut our deficits by more than half
partly by making sure the wealthiest
Americans folks like me paid their fair
share of taxes okay we did not cut the
deficit in half so let's stop it right
there when he says we cut the deficit in
half what he means by that is that he
blew out the deficit in his first year
and then the deficit numbers went down
the next couple of years and the reason
that that is cutting in half that's like
saying you know what I did last month
last month I went ten thousand dollars
over my credit card bill this month I
went five thousand dollars over my
credit card bill I just cut my deficit
in half that's what he's talking about
that's I'm cutting your deficit in half
I mean technically it sort of is but not
really considering that you're still
blowing out the spending but again
Barack Obama was the was the creator of
the Trump phenomenon for the left to
refuse to acknowledge this putting it
out on the campaign
well it's such a mistake but this is the
thing the Democrats really don't have a
lot to offer at this point and so they
are doubling down on on stupid the only
person who seems to be discovering
anything new ironically is Hillary
Clinton discuss that in just a second so
Hillary Clinton when one of the things I
do love about the Trump era is that the
left suddenly realizes that when the
levers of power are given to the other
party things don't wind up great for the
left so the left is all in favor of
federal power as long as it's Barack
Obama in charge when it's president
Trump in charge suddenly they discover
federal power is bad now I'm pretty
consistent on this I think federal power
sucks all the way through
I think the first rule of good
governance is don't create a weapon that
can then be wielded by the other side
now folks on the Left have for gun
control you know what I'm for I'm for
federal power control he reduced the
amount of federal power available to
anyone and then you are not going to
have to worry about the federal power
being used against you one of the great
ironies though is that Hillary Clinton
one of the great advocates of federal
power of the modern era she is now
discovering federalism again amazing how
this works
Donald Trump comes along suddenly
Hillary Clinton and the left are
discovering that states are kind of
great here's what she tweeted yesterday
in reality of a Supreme Court with a
right-wing majority is that the states
are a new important front in protecting
civil rights especially the rights of
the most vulnerable among us is that
really a new important front and
protecting civil rights or does it turn
out that the states were always an
important front in protecting civil
rights now folks are gonna say well
think about the fact that states were
responsible for Jim Crow that's true it
was also states that were responsible
for failing to abide by the Fugitive
Slave Act and then 1850s leading to the
Civil War the federal government was
trying to force states in the north to
abide by the Fugitive Slave Act states
in the North were refusing to abide by
the Fugitive Slave Act states are only
as good as the people who comprise them
and their policy is only as good as the
people who comprise them but one thing
that is certainly true is that the
United States as a mixed state and and
national system as it is put in
Federalist 39 as a mixed system state
governments are designed to preserve the
centrality of locality in American
jurisprudence and the fact that the left
is only now realizing this as soon as
somebody who's in office they don't like
is that the head of the federal
demonstrates just how dishonest they are
because here's the thing Hillary Clinton
and her ilk if they ever got in charge
again how long do you think they'd stick
by the states rights proposal how long
do you think they'd be in favor of
states rights the answer is five seconds
five seconds at the left is just
dishonest about all the stuff the same
left that proclaims that Donald Trump is
dishonest this is dishonest when Hillary
Clinton says she likes states rights
know what Hillary Clinton means is that
she wants to use any obstacle to prevent
President Trump from governing but she
doesn't actually believe in states
rights if she actually believed in the
states rights then presumably she'd want
a devolution of authority to the states
from the federal government across the
board including if she had been
president we all know that that was
never going to happen we all know that
was never gonna happen instead the truth
is what Democrats really wants is to
copy the policies of Scandinavian
countries where people forget to tell
you this but the policy in Scandinavian
countries is not just a massive social
welfare state is a massive social
welfare state paid for by enormous
unbelievably high taxes the taxes in
places like Denmark and Norway fifty to
sixty percent on everybody making more
than fifty or sixty grand a year we're
not talking about taxes on just the
wealthy even folks on the left are not
willing to be honest about what exactly
it would take to pay for all the crap
that they are talking about instead what
they will do is they will just kick the
can down the road so what exactly are
they proposing so they're not really
proposing federalism and they're not
obviously proposing fact-based
legislation the left is proposing
spending a lot of money so now we are
going to get in these twenty twenty
primaries from the Democrats who can
spend the most cash so we have Kamala
Harris who's proposing giving every poor
family five hundred bucks based on
nothing we really don't know where
exactly this money is going to come from
how this is going to spur the economy
any of that stuff Cory Booker says well
why do five hundred why not do a hundred
times five hundred let's give everybody
50 grand so why not give her be five
hundred grand by the way why not five
million why don't just helicopter
pallets of cash over Newark and we'll
just drop pallets of cash I mean
hopefully people get out of the way if
not they'll be crushed by money and die
happy that apparently is the idea from
Cory Booker so according to Vox which is
the repository of all things stupid
that's not to say that everybody ad Vox
is stupid there's some
intelligent folks at Vauxhall though why
they remain there is beyond me senator
Cory Booker is introducing a bill aimed
at closing the gap between rich and poor
his idea is to give lower-income kids a
sizeable nest egg nearly 50 grand in
some cases that they could use for
wealth building purchases like a down
payment on a house or college tuition
these opportunity accounts would
theoretically make sure all children
have significant assets when they enter
adulthood rather than just those who
grew up in wealthier homes well you know
what this particular proposal relies on
people to use money well you know what
else relies on people to use money well
basic reason and free markets so
dropping cash on people without actually
using that cash for good purposes is
counterproductive we're gonna get to
some more of the Democratic agenda the
reason base Democratic agenda Barak
Obama talks about in just one second
first let's talk about your underwear so
dudes fall is here and as you switch out
your wardrobe don't neglect the undies
now is a perfect time to upgrade or
restock your drawers with all new fall
colors and prints from Tommy John Tommy
John obsesses over every little detail
and stitch these proprietary fabrics
that perform like nothing you've worn
before
as a result Tommy John's men's and
women's underwear they support a no
wedgie guaranteed comfortable stay put
waist bands and a range of fabrics that
are luxuriously soft feather-light
moisture wicking breathable and designed
to move with you not against you that
means no bunching no riding up Tommy
John is so confident in their underwear
if you don't love your first pair and
get a full refund with their best pair
you'll ever wear or it's free guarantee
so you really don't have anything to
lose that includes their new life
changing women's underwear which are now
fully back in stock crated Tommy John
comm / Ben right now get 20% off your
first order the underwear fantastic I'm
wearing them right now
I have many pairs of Tommy John
underwear because they are so good
that's Tommy John comm / Ben for 20% off
one of the great things about these
underwear by the way is that no matter
how many times you put them in the wash
they still operate they don't fall apart
at the drop of a hat go to Tommy John's
calm right now Tommy John / Ben for 20%
off okay so the democratic fact-based
agenda now revolves around Kamala Harris
offering everybody 500 bucks and Cory
Booker offering everybody 50,000 bucks
paid for by hey here's here's what the
American Opportunity accounts program
would look like every child upon being
born would be given an account
with $1000 every year through the tax
code children would receive up to an
additional $2,000 deposit depending on
family income funds would sit in a
low-risk account managed by Treasury
with roughly 3% annual returns account
holders may not access the money until
they reach age 18 and the only allowable
uses our education home ownership and
retirement okay so in other words we are
just going to basically buy a house and
an education for you paid for by mm-hmm
nobody really knows okay so that that's
really great you know it's another way
of doing this actually and say if
usually want to help young people you
know it's another way of doing this
privatizing Social Security because
that's basically what he's talking about
here he's basically talking about taking
people's retirement savings and putting
them in an account for them a lockbox
for them for many many years and then
giving them to them much later it's it's
it all sounds great except for exactly
how this this money is going to be
generated and folks on the Left never
talk about how the money is generated
they just talk about free money so part
one of the Democrats new agenda is
apparently according to Hillary Clinton
federalism so congratulations to all of
us that's been around for a couple
hundred years now Democrats are
discovering it part two is give people
lots and lots of free money and part
three is hating science because part
three is science is stupid and we don't
need it anymore
so yesterday we talked at length about
this new proposal from the Trump
administration to define sex as you know
the dictionary definition of sex like
there are males and females and we
talked about the left weird attempt to
separate gender from sex and then to
retro actively conflate sex and gender
they're exactly the same thing and
they're really pushing this hard now
there's a person named Jennifer Finney
Boylan who is a genetic male which is to
say a male human and has had a bunch of
surgeries and now considers himself
female the the piece in the new york
times is called trump cannot define away
my existence and this is so weird this I
love this argument from the left you
can't define away my existence you
literally define away the existence of
millions of unborn children every single
year they don't exist according to you
now transgender people exist according
to me but that does not mean that they
are actually members of the sex to which
they claim membership right I can I can
fully acknowledge the people who suffer
from mental
from the mental disorder known as gender
identity disorder or gender dysphoria
those people exist of course they exist
I mean they're there I know some of them
like okay that's not the same thing as
saying that you are actually a woman if
you say that you are a woman and again
there's no objective evidence there's no
objective test I can use to determine
that you are a woman if you say that you
are a woman but here's the piece in the
New York Times the anti-science piece of
the New Democratic agenda feelings over
fact here is this piece by Jennifer
Finney Boylan I was surprised to learn
on Sunday morning that I do not exist
well that's weird
she says this will come as sad news to
my children to whom I've been a mother
for over 20 years now well presumably
you were a father at one point to your
children and will come as a shock to my
wife - to whom I've been married for 30
years it would have been a
disappointment for my mother as well the
conservative evangelical Christian
Republican who when she learned I was
transgender two decades ago said I would
never turn my back on my child and then
quote in first Corinthians these three
remain Faith Hope and love but the
greatest of these is love okay that's
that's fine but it also says in the
Bible that male and female he created
them so I mean if we're gonna
selectively quote the Bible you may as
well quote the whole thing there's been
a hard life for me these last 60 years
but on the whole I felt grateful for the
many blessings that have come my way and
being trans not least it is so
disappointing then and more than a
little embarrassing to learn I'm
imaginary a creature no more real than a
cyclops or a Hippogriff again you're
real human but you're not a real woman
you know why because you are not
genetically a real woman now you want to
say that you are a gender that you're
gendered feminine that you are a male
who had surgeries to look more female
and that you carry feminine attributes
that is accurate that is accurate use of
language it is not accurate use of
language to say that you're a female on
Sunday news broke that the Trump
administration seeks to narrowly define
gender as an immutable condition
determined by genitalia at birth well
actually they were identifying sex that
way and then you guys conflate sex and
gender so you say it's the same thing I
admit I'm reluctant to react to this
latest cruelty which is obviously just
one more cynical move clearly designed
to stir the pot ahead of the election
trans people are the latest conservative
whipping girl like African Americans in
the 1950s or gay people in the 1990s and
2000's nope nope
gay people can objectively claim to be
attracted to members of the same sex
that's a subjective claim there is no
way to objectively verify that so that
is what it is
I can objectively verify your sex for a
variety of measures okay and black
people a white person who claims that
they're a black person is not in fact a
black person as Rachel Dolezal learned I
was speaking at the f scott fitzgerald
festival in rockville maryland this
weekend when i first read about the
administration's intents since then i've
thought about a lot about Nick Carraway
in the Great Gatsby and then this this
continues instead the actual world
contains all sorts of wonderful
variations of nature look there are two
cans and puffins there's a duck-billed
platypus in a blue lobster the Venus
flytrap isn't in a miracle that God has
given us all these wonderful things
surely if there's room in this world for
these there should be room in this world
for me there again nobody is suggesting
that transgender people should be
mistreated but you do not get to tell
the entire civilization to redefine
biological sex on the basis of anti
science positions because how you feel
on the inside my favorite part of this
piece is the suggestion that science is
on the side of this policy there is no
science on the side of the policy
promulgated by the left that sex does
not exist so they started off with sex
exists but gender is unconnected with
sex and then they went to gender exists
but it exists on a spectrum then they
went to sex exists again but it only
exists on a spectrum respect to sex
didn't exist for a while now it exists
again but it only exists on a spectrum
there's a spectrum of sex there's no
spectrum of sex human beings are
sexually dimorphic okay if you want to
suggest that there are other species
where sex can change fine but you are
not you're not a fish you're not one of
these fish that changes sexes hey you
are a human among humans sex does not
change that's not the way this works but
this has been pushed by the hard left
and so you get the odd spectacle of
Stephen Colbert tut-tutting Trump
telling President Trump on this trans
issue and how telling is the remark that
he's about to make er it's pretty
telling I'll explain why in a second
the Trump administration is thinking
about writing new guidelines that say
gender should be defined quote on a
biological basis that is clear grounded
in science oh now you care about science
and listen to the crowd cheer that now
you kept shouldn't you be happy that
they care about science I'm confused
so you say that when it comes to climate
change that the Trump administration is
utterly anti-scientific when it comes to
the EPA they're utterly anti-scientific
and that's bad but now they care about
science when it comes to biological sex
and that's bad does he even see the
hypocrisy and what he's saying himself
the answer is no because to the left
even science is malleable now my
position on climate change I've made
clear multiple times on this program I
did like an entire program on it a
couple of weeks ago talking about the
new IPCC report the world is warming
it's warming at a slower rate than the
scientists said it was going to
according to their modeling probably a
majority of that warming according to
every scientist I've ever seen including
Roy Spencer who is the Wrights favorite
climate scientist suggests that the
majority of that warming is due to human
action that does not dictate global
governance of the climate nor does it
dictate that we have to crush capitalism
in spirit or an action but that is
considered an anti scientific position
by the left it is considered a and it is
considered I guess bad form to mention
science when it comes to biological sex
now if this is the new democratic
position good luck with this guy's good
luck okay so in just a second we'll talk
about some other democratic positions
and why the news cycle continues to cut
in favor of the President of the United
States first let me remind you that you
don't have to go to the post office
today I know you need stamps the post
office is great they have a lot of great
services but you don't actually have to
get in your car and go down to the post
office that's not a thing you have to do
you don't have to spend the time instead
all you have to do is log on to
stamps.com with stamps calm you can get
all the amazing services of the post
office right from your desk 24/7 when it
is convenient for you buy and print
official US postage for any letter any
package using your own computer and
printer the mail carrier picks it up
just click print mail you're done could
not be easier we use stamps calm here at
the Daily wire offices to send letters
and packages merchandise for the show go
over to stamps calm you can do it too
right now use promo code Shapiro for
this special offer 55 bucks of free post
postage a digital scale and a four week
trial again go to stamps calm before you
do anything else click on the radio
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in promo code Shapiro that
stamps comm promo code Shapiro go check
it out right now
again stamps.com promo code Shapiro will
use it at the office because it is great
and it saves lots of time and for us
time is money
go to stamps calm again promo code
Shapiro for that special deal 55 bucks
and free postage a digital scale and a
four week trial it's a great service go
check it out right now okay so I want to
talk a little bit more about the science
of transgenderism and and I want to get
into the specific details because I want
to rebut all the arguments that you're
gonna hear made by the left over the
next few years as they try to turn
transgenderism into the new civil rights
movement but first you're gonna have to
go over to daily where calm and
subscribe to watch it live for $9.99 a
month get the rest of this program why
I've got the rest of Michael Noel's this
show terrible his terrible show life get
the rest of it Enric Levin's good show
life get all of those things and then
you can also be part of our mailbag
which we do on Fridays here you get to
be part of our mailbag when we do daily
wire backstage we have another one of
those coming up election night we have
all sorts of goodies that are coming out
on a routine basis for $99 a year you
also get this the travel mug the leftist
cheers hot or cold tumbler look at this
thing feast your eyes upon it it is in
fact Laureus $99 a year gets you the
subscription along with that the travel
mug and when you subscribe in iTunes and
leave us a five star review then I
believe you you get the Sunday special
as well in your feed and we have a
Sunday special this week that's just
awesome like really I'm very excited
about our Sunday special this this week
it's really really great so go check
that out
also I would urge you if you're a
listener to the show apparently
iHeartRadio has a new they actually have
a new podcast Awards that they are
giving out all you have to do is go to I
heart comm and then check out their
podcast Awards I mean we just go to I
heart comm then you can see at the very
top it's I heart comm slash podcast -
awards and you can vote up to five times
a day it's like the North Korean
elections all you have to do is go to
the news section and then vote for me
five times that we can beat out pod save
America does it matter
but it's fun anyway it'll be fun
bragging rights so go check it out at I
heart comm and we can win that award if
if you see that we are fit to do so we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so how stupid is the left agenda with
regard to the anti science nonsense
pushed by the transgender movement this
is an actual tweet from New York Times
science the idea that a person's sex is
determined by their Anatomy at birth is
not true and we've known that it's not
true for decades okay
well realistically speaking I suppose
that's not true in the only in the most
only the most narrow sense it is
determined by chromosomes right is
determined by genetics and theoretically
you could have some sort of birth
malformation when you are born that
leaves you bereft of the genitalia that
match up with your actual genetics so I
guess in the very narrowest sense it's
true but the idea that that means that
sex is on a spectrum among humans is
just stupid I love this headline though
Anatomy does not determine gender
experts say right genetics determines
gender I love this researchers who have
studied gender issues and provided
health care to people who do not fit the
typical male-female pigeonholes the
typical male-female pigeonholes is
though they're just created by society
said that the Trump administration's
latest plan to define gender goes beyond
the limits of scientific knowledge the
idea that a person's sex is determined
by their Anatomy at birth is not true
and we've known that it is not true for
decades as John says Joshua safer and
endocrinologist and the executive
director of the sister of the Center for
transgender medicine and surgery of
course at the Mount Sinai Health System
in New York you don't talk about a
scientific stuff ok talk about whether
there are beneficial effects to
transgender surgeries over time ok there
is not good evidence to suggest that the
end effect over the course of decades is
actually significantly superior to no
surgery and yet this has become part of
the transgender movement stick now let
me be clear we live in a free country
you want to go carve up your own
genitals that's your problem right you
can find a surgeon who's willing to do
that for you go for it it's a free
country but let's not pretend that the
science is on the side of all of the
claims that are being made I love this
it buried down in this article they say
genetics does play a role though oh you
think oh you think so it's it's by the
way you know how you know that it's not
just genitalia because of a male were to
have his twig and berries physically
removed in some sort of accident he
would still be a male and if he intends
to do so in a surgery we are now
supposed to consider him a female okay
that is it that is not logical I want to
talk for just a second
about the sort of propaganda that's been
promoted on this issue and it really is
insane propaganda so the the notion that
is pushed by the left that
transgenderism is not a mental disorder
is completely a scientific hey now what
the left does is they'd like to cite
things like the Diagnostic and
Statistical Manual because the dsm-5
suggests that gender identity disorder
is no longer a mental disorder instead
what the dsm-5 says is that a mental
disorder is a quote syndrome
characterized by clinically significant
disturbance in an individual's cognition
emotion regulation or behavior that
reflects a dysfunction in the
psychological biological or
developmental processes underlying
mental functioning now this is the this
is the the funny part socially deviant
behavior and conflicts that are
primarily between the individual and
society are not mental disorders unless
the deviance or conflict results from a
dysfunction in the individual is
described about so in other words if you
have something that makes you think that
a pink elephant is stalking you
unless this makes you feel bad this is
not actually a mental disorder according
to the DSM the definition makes room for
its making clear room for politically
correct posturing right if I am having a
significant problem in and of myself all
I have to do is blame it on society's
intolerance and it is no longer
considered a mental disorder okay so if
you are suicidal because you're a man
who believes he's a woman the DSM can
still find a way to blame that on
society all you have to say is the
reason I'm suicidal is because people
are mean to me in society not because I
have suffered with this terrible
conflict inside my inside my brain for
my entire life right now society's fault
is how the dsm-5 avoids the obvious
implication that if you're man who
believes you're woman you have a mental
disorder if you're by the way if you're
a fat person who believes you are skinny
or a skinny person who believes you are
fat we all acknowledge you of mental
disorder if you are a skinny person who
believes you're a fat it's called
anorexia it's dangerous and it's a
mental disorder if you're a person who
believes that you do not need a left arm
right this is something called body
dysmorphia this is a mental disorder but
if you're a man who believes you're a
woman and you don't need your penis then
it's not a mental disorder it's
society's fault you explain that one to
me ain't none of this has anything to do
with science and all of it is
specifically designed to blame society
for what is clearly and obviously a
mental disorder the reason that I'm
serious about calling it a mental
disorder the reason I do so is because
you
to actually treat a mental disorder by
blaming it on society if you want to
come up with new treatments for mental
disorder the way to do that is not by
saying that society at large is
responsible for the discomfort of people
suffering from the mental disorder I'm
somebody who takes mental illness
extraordinarily seriously
my grandfather was either bipolar or
schizophrenic there are some lines that
are that are hard to sort of diagnose
there he was institutionalized when my
dad was a child he thought the radio was
talking to him he thought the curtains
were trying to strangle him he suffered
from that that was not something or if
we had blamed society's intolerance and
just said you know what Nate the radio
actually is talking to you it's just
society can't hear what you hear that
would have been foolish they gave him
lithium and he was much better that does
not mean there's a good treatment for
gender identity disorder gender
dysphoria but to pretend that the
treatments are all available and that
transitioning is the only available sort
of fix and that everything else is
society's fault is anti-scientific in
the extreme and to quote the DSM which
is a political football and has been a
political football for decades as these
sort of apotheosis of scientific
knowledge is just silly
it's just silly they are definitely the
definition of mental disorder itself is
not scientific according to dsm-5 it is
that there's no way that you can pose a
hypothesis and then debunk it it is not
scientifically verifiable okay with all
of that said the left has embraced a
bunch of positions that are
unsustainable I believe in American
politics the the latest position they
are embracing that is unsustainable in
American politics has to do with this
migrant Caravan so this migrant caravan
as we mentioned yesterday is now
approaching the American border with
presumably the help of the Mexican
government you can see the Mexican
authorities are driving alongside the
caravan it is now ten thousand people
large and it is moving toward the border
now there are processes for asylum in
the United States all you have to do is
go to a US Embassy and apply or you can
go to a border checkpoint and apply you
can see the pictures if you're if you're
able to watch this because you subscribe
it daily wire.com you can see the
pictures I mean these are these are
marches stretching a mile long ten wide
there's an enormous enormous number of
people well President Trump he got
himself into trouble yesterday because
he said listen there are some bad people
who are coming in this in this care
right now are there bad people coming in
the caravan who the hell knows the
answer is we don't know the answer to
that I presumably some
those people are bad presumably many of
those people are not bad but the answer
is we don't know who they are so how can
we possibly open our borders this way
what's happening right now
as a large group of people the court a
caravan and in that Caravan you have
some very bad people you have some very
bad people and we can't let that happen
to our country okay so you know he's
maybe right maybe he's wrong but we
don't know now what the left proclaims
that we should let all of these people
in presumably but then why not let in
the next caravan or all caravans does
everyone who wants to come to the United
States because they're coming from a bad
situation have the right to come into
the United States now I am pretty
libertarian when it comes to people who
are immigrating for employment reasons
this is why I think that we ought to let
in more people through legal immigration
methods in the United States but let's
recognize something the social structure
of the United States is not the same in
2018 as it was in 1907 the reason I use
1907 is that's when my ancestors got
here the comparison here is not between
the ethnicities of the folks showing up
I don't care about ethnicity I really
don't it makes no difference to me the
question is what is the social system
that people are being integrated into
when my great-great grandparents got to
the United States when they got here in
1907 and they arrived on the boats they
spoke Yiddish and had no money and there
was no social safety net there
immediately thrust into a capitalist
economy where they had to learn English
and they had that they were forced by
circumstance into assimilating
specifically so that they could operate
in the economy of the United States and
become good American citizens there were
people who left stuff behind in their
home country to come to the United
States
so that they could actually live a
better more adventurous life now I think
a lot of immigrants still want that but
the fact that we have a social safety
net that picks up after everybody the
fact that if you have a baby in the
United States that baby is now an
American citizen and you can take
advantage of all of the benefits of
American citizenship that there are all
these you know tremendous social safety
nets available to you means we have to
be a little bit more circumspect about
who we let in the country and again
citing the Scandinavian countries the
Scandinavian countries are really tough
on immigration they're very tough on
immigration and they should be because
the richer your social safety net the
more folks are going to want to take
advantage of it and let's not pretend
that there's no anti-american animus
this met in his Caravan there clearly is
you can look at some of the pictures
alright so some of the folks who are who
are marching we're carrying the Honduran
flag so this one I believe is actually
from Honduras and so let's go back to
the Honduran flag one so you can see at
the front of this March there are people
who are carrying the hunter and flag now
the claim of the caravan is that these
are people who are attempting to escape
from Honduras Honduras is a bad place
right it's a place where they can't live
the life they want to live it's a place
of little Economic Opportunity so why
are you carrying the flag of that place
when Cuban refugees got on to nineteen
fifty Chevy's inflated the tires and
tried to float their way to Florida they
weren't carrying a Cuban flag when they
arrived on American shores they were
trying to escape Cuba that was sort of
the point
if you're marching from Honduras to
escape Honduras why are you coming here
with a Honduran flag when my ancestors
got here they weren't carrying a Russian
or Lithuanian flag they came to the
United States ready to carry an American
flag that is the point this idea that
you can assimilate all cultures
including people who forcibly do not
want to be assimilated in a social
safety net society is just not accurate
and yet that's what Democrats continue
to promote I mean over in Honduras by
the way in support of the migrants
they've been burning American flags at
some of these protests this is a famous
picture going around yesterday somebody
painted a swastika on the American flag
and then burned it so then why do folks
who want in America's Nazi Germany is
not really a great pitch as to I also
want to enter there you know that that
push again it leads folks to the
position that President Trump has taken
where he says he's a nationalist not a
globalist now President Trump said this
in a rally yesterday that he's a
nationalist not a globalist I've
distinguished between nationalism and
patriotism
I'm not a big nationalist in the sense
that I don't think that simple borders
and living in the same place is enough
of a rationale for you to be enthused I
think that instead you actually have to
be about ideas but what he's reacting to
is the left's focus on globalism the
left belief that there should be no
borders that people should be able to
cross willy-nilly in to the United
States and never assimilate because
multiculturalism is the way to go you
want to know why President Trump is
popular it's because of this
is a person that wants the globe to do
well frankly not caring about our
country so much and you know what we
can't have that you know they have a
word it sort of became old-fashioned
it's called a nationalist and I say
really we're not supposed to use that
word you know what I am I'm a
nationalist okay okay the reason that
you're not supposed to use the word
nationalist typically is because it's
largely been connected with repressive
regimes who are focused in on
commonalities in ethnicity and culture
as opposed to commonalities and ideas
but if he is posing sort of American
interests against folks who want
inundation of our borders then that's
perfectly rational
that's perfectly rational okay so it's
time for our way up to some things I
like in things I hate is that we're okay
so let's do some things that I like and
some things that I hate so things that I
like today there's a book that was
recommended to me by Andrew Clavin I've
been I've been going through kind of
Drew's reading list it's called the Last
Supper
by Charles Meharry and it's a really
good sort of action thriller dating all
the way back it's it's heard of Cold War
thriller that dates all the way back to
the 1920s and then carries forward
through the Vietnam War it's really
worth the read it's really well written
and I'm sort of a devotee of action
thrillers at least old-fashioned ones
I'm one of my favorite books of the day
of the jackal by Frederick Forsythe
which is the best action thriller in the
history of literature it's so good but
this one is quite good too Charles
Mackerras the Last Supper
wertha read go check it out that's
that's worth checking out okay other
things that I like today I do enjoy PETA
the People for the Ethical Treatment of
Animals because they're totally crazy so
I I do enjoy them here is what they
tweeted out yesterday cow's milk has
long been a symbol used by white
supremacists one more reason to hashtag
ditch dairy really didn't know that was
a thing so apparently I knew is the
thing only because the New York Times we
talked about a piece earlier this week
in which white supremacist were guzzling
cow's milk to demonstrate their genetic
superiority because they could tolerate
lactose which again seems like not the
world's most important skill set like
you can't really put on your resume
tolerates lactose well that's not
something that like if somebody put that
on the rez
pay for the daily wear but this person
is not getting hired but but Peter's
response is just as stupid which is not
why should cow's milk be used by white
supremacists it's cow's milk itself is
indeed white supremacists so you should
not use cow's milk anymore goat's milk
apparently not white supremacist so
that's good to know so I guess forcible
milking of the goats is on its way and
also what do you do if you like
chocolate milk you like chocolate milk
are you also white supremacists further
questions my children big fans of milk
really enjoy it did ever since they were
babies it turns out were they weight
supremacist when they were small babies
his babies like cow's milk
true true story so PETA doing yeoman's
work in demonstrating just how insane
they are each and every day of the week
well done well done
PETA okay time for a couple of things
that I hate a thing number one that I
hate
a new study 25% of students say they
were traumatized by the 2016 election
researchers surveyed Arizona State
University students around the time of
president Trump's inauguration in 2017
some had stress scores on par with that
of seven month follow-ups to school
shooting witnesses 25% of the 769
students reported clinically significant
levels of stress women black Hispanic
non-christian students reported higher
stress so apparently they now say that
they are suffering basically from
post-traumatic stress disorder not
kidding this is the this is this is
actually what they're saying so they're
saying they suffer from PTSD a quarter
of these students they found it so
traumatic they now report symptoms of
PTSD according to the study so things
that cause PTSD for young people in the
past 1910s World War one trench warfare
1920s aftermath of World War one in
trench warfare 1930s the Great
Depression and mass starvation 1940s
World War two the 1960s the Vietnam War
the 1970s vast social unrest bombings in
the United States 2018 you lost an
election oh you pansies i prescribed to
you avec take some avocado toast and
call me in the morning
they really
PTSD PTSD from an election listen when
John Kerry was poised to win in 2004 I
was living in Cambridge Massachusetts
because going to Harvard Law at the time
and well I was and while I was there
John Kerry was supposed to speak just
down the road the entire town was abuzz
because John Kerry was gonna be the next
president I went to Tower Records which
used to exist it used to be a place kids
and Tower Records was a place where they
sold this thing called CDs and CDs were
these things that had music on them and
you played them so I went over to Tower
Records in in Harvard Square and I
bought myself Mozart's Requiem and
prepared for a deep depressing evening
as it turns out the 2004 election was
great but I was prepared was that PTSD
no it wasn't and come on it man up man
up come the hell on if this is the
generation we are reliant upon no no I
think well I think we're all screwed I
think that's fair to say we're screwed
if if a quarter of all humans were a
quarter of all students were given were
stressed some level of PTSD
yeah we're jacked the United States is
over okay other things that I hate
there's actually a thing that I like so
Amy Schumer confirmed that she was
pregnant and she tweeted out Chris she's
married Chris and I are thrilled in
almost positive he's the father which is
funny okay well just I'd like to make a
quick point I am extraordinarily excited
and happy that Amy Schumer has a
meaningless cluster of cells in her womb
could not be happier for her about this
now do I believe it's meaningless
cluster cells of course not that's the
point I think it's a baby which is why
it makes sense for me to be happy when
people are pregnant
what makes less sense is the idea that I
can be happy about this meaningless
cluster of cells in my womb if it's me
but if it's somebody else I have no way
to be happy for them because what do
they think maybe maybe they think it's a
meaningless cluster of cells presumably
if Amy Schumer wanted to abort this
cluster of cells it would just be a
cluster of cells the same people who say
that we are erasing transgender people
by saying transgender people exist but
are not members of the opposite sex
which is biologically true say that
babies don't exist because they are
meaningless clusters of cells embryos
are just meaningless clusters of cells
which is both anti-scientific and
erasing human beings so there's that
okay you know what that's enough for
today I'm regularly so we're gonna we're
going to
another show tomorrow we will be back
here then I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah alvera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018